mélodie est une fée l'a fait de la
musique avec l on découvre les
partitions les notes ses notes si
importantes pour créer mais voilà
patatras
un coup de vent et le public suit alors
le voyage de mélodies pour retrouver
cette note
créé en 2011 le fabuleux voyage l'a fait
mélodie est aussi interactif je le vis
aussi surtout à travers en fait toutes
les toutes les interactions que je sais
faire aux enfants
donc en fait pendant le spectacle qui
sont très participatif puisque entre
chaque tableau d'ombrés chinoises
je les sollicite pour m'aider dans ma
quête de la recherche du là avec un peu
de magie et beaucoup de poésie
stéphanie marino multiplie les
inspirations pour émerveiller petits et
grands de mary poppins aux ogres de
barback en passant par noir désir et
alice au pays des merveilles ya plein
d'univers différents qui m'ont inspiré
pour l'écriture des textes il ya plein
de textes eux-mêmes qui m'ont inspiré
comme par exemple le petit prince aussi
et dans vie en fait est venu au départ
de raconter une histoire autour de la
musique pour les petits pour les initier
un peu à ce qu'est la musique avec un
univers très féerique très poétique
un autre coup de vent peut toujours
arriver là fut mélodie vous attend à
versailles jusqu'au 26 octobre